they actually believe Marxism makes
sense because they don't know what
they're talking about you see these
videos of young people saying the
stupidest things you've ever heard and
you're like men uh Greta tunberg I mean
she's not American but she's outright
saying kill 60 million people overnight
when she says we must end fossil fuss
now we're not going to vet it's like
okay yeah if you ended fossil fuels
right now like New York just banned
natural gas these people their brains
are broken
this is a lot about this they've been
they've been wrapped up on this social
media algorithmic garbage that tells
them whatever whatever the algorithm
promotes that's what you must adhere to
so these young people see climate change
as bad then you end up with a politician
saying tell me what to do so you'll vote
for me and they say bad natural gas okay
no more gas stoves are you kidding one
this natural gas is a large component of
how we generate electricity how about we
do nuclear power no these people are too
moronic because of what they read on the
internet to know nuclear power is clean
and actually the best way to generate
electricity